よろしくお願いします
えっと あの 一応とりあえず一部はこの質問に答えようといたします
それから 次にまた新しい疑問やら質問やら何かできたならば
その時その時答えさせていただきます
まああの 今日のテーマは待機説法というテーマで
で なんか最近 まあ何言うかわからないというふうな紹介をされましたけどもね
全然信頼されてないということで
で うーん まあ待機説法について喋るということはあまりにもアホらしいんですからね
で 待機説法っていうのは
その人に理解できるように喋るということ
その人に理解できるように喋るということについて喋るのさというと
まあそれはまあ 仏教用語の理解の問題でございます
まあとにかく まあその大義説法について
後で何か時間があったらお話しさせていただきます
まず 我々日常生活でできてくるいろいろ質問について考えてみましょう
一番先に出てきた質問は
この慈悲の瞑想というのは
まあ私の言葉に入れ替えますけどね
おかしいじゃないかということをね
まあ矛盾ではないかと
仏教である面で欲望は苦しみだよと言いながら
ある面反面で一生懸命欲望を作っていると
もう何何者かというふうなね
風に まあそういうふうに質問が頭の中で入れ替えた方が分かりやすいんです
ある反面で欲望は苦しみの元ですよと
ということを言うと 我々の経験でやっぱり欲望があるんだから
大変な苦しみがあるということはわかっているんです
それである反面で 慈悲の瞑想をしようとしたところで
私の願うことは叶いますよと言っちゃうと
これ欲望の塊ではないかと
だからこんな矛盾があっていいのかというふうに考えるかもしれません
で そこでそういう質問ができるのは
あの この慈悲って何ですか？という慈悲についての理解とかね
あるいは慈悲はなぜできているんですかということを理解すると
なんとかなるだろうと思います
瞑想と言っても 仏教でいう言葉はバーワナという言葉なんです
仏教でよく使う言葉 何回も同じ言葉を書きましたから
バーワナ バーワナっていうのは
このサンスクリット語のブーという動詞から出ていて
意味が成長するということですから
育てる 育む 成長する 進化するという意味でバーワナという言葉なんです
瞑想という意味は全くないんです
で 何か一つの文句を何回何回も繰り返すことには瞑想らしい言葉を使いますけど
その時はだいたいアヌッサティ
サティという 2つの言葉を使うんですね
だいたいアヌッサティ
サティ もうこれはヴィパッサナーで使うサティとは似ていて似ていないなんですけどね
で 何か我々は何か文句を一つ頭の中で繰り返し繰り返し念じたりする場合は
アヌッサティと言うんですね
お祈りみたいなもんなんですね
それも前にする言葉によって
アヌッサティはアヌは取ってしまってサティだけでも言う場合もあります
あの それは日本訳すると念じるということになるんですね
だから念仏はパーリ語ではブッダアヌッサティなんですね
念仏にはブッダアヌッサティというんです
ブッダアヌッサティ   そういうのはいくらか瞑想みたいなものなんですね
でも そういういろいろ修行法をまとめて
仏教で一般的に使う言葉はバハルナ
バハルナっていうのは意味は育てる
成長する 発展するという意味なんですね
という そこで出てくる考え方は
まあそのまま放っておけば何にもならないんだと
世の中を見ても 放っておけば何にもならない
我々の心をしたっても
放っておけば何にもならない
そのまんまで 大体放っておくと
自然法則ではどうなるかというと
どんどんこの腐食していっちゃうんですね
どんどん退化してしまう
堕落してしまうんです
で そういうわけで放っておくわけにはいきません
ですから 自然の物理的な法則にだって
我々に見えているのは
例えば いくら新しい家を買ってそのまま放っておいてみてください
そうすると早くも家が腐食して住めなくなってしまうんですね
そこで放っておかないで
まあ 1週間に一回でも埃を拭いたり
掃除をしたり まあちょっと面倒を見てあげると
20年ぐらいはもう何の問題もなく
家がまあ生きていられるんです
で まあそれでも腐食するんだけど
一応まあ放っておくと腐食する
堕落する もう退化してしまう
ですから放っておかないで
ただもうちょっと面倒見るだけではなくて
育ててみようと まあ例で言うならば
たまにこのいろいろ手作業好きな男性の方々は
この誰かに この業者の人に家作ってくださいと頼まないで
なんとかちょっとしたお金でちょっと土地を買って
コツコツと自分でまず小さな部屋を一つ作ると
それからまたあっちこっちから材料を持ってきて
もう一つ付け加えると
まあそうやってどんどんどんどん
まあまあ月1回とか なんとかちょっと一つ付け加える
そこでもうじゃあ一回ですから
もう二回も作りましょうとか
じゃあ今度は台所をちょっと作ってみようとか
自分の手作業で作るとする
そうすると  1年  2年  3年経つと
5,000万とか 6,000万とか
お金を払ってでも作られないほどの
全く自分の注文通りの家ができちゃうんです
それで他の人を見たら
この家はあなたにぴったしですよと
どれぐらいお金がかかったんですか？ってびっくりするかもしれません
で 本人でいえ まあ最初の値段ぐらいです
まあせいぜい 800万ぐらいでしょうとか言うかもしれません
私はまあコツコツ自分で作ったんだと
そういう感じで その例えなんです
それで あの ただ心の埃を拭いて面倒見るだけではなくて
コツコツと心を育てると
まあ立派なものになるんです
その意味で仏教ではバハナという言葉を使っているんです
これは心の面倒を見るだけではなくて
心をまあちょっとずつちょっとずつ
まあ成長させる じゃあ次に慈悲って何ですか？ということ
慈悲っていうのは出てきて
のは 生命は本来自己主義で自分のことしか考えてないんです
それから自分のことしか考えられないんです
それは生命の本来の状態
一個一個の生命というのは
まあ自分のことはわかりませんだけど
自分のことさえも でも考えているのは自分のこと
それ以外のことは考えられない
たまたま私は冗談で自分のことしか考えられないと言うんだけど
あんた本当に自分のこと知ってますかと
まあ冗談で言うんだけど
まあ結局自分のことを知らないというのは
お釈迦様の教えで それは置いておいて
生命は自分のことしか考えない
それから私が言うのは考えられない
自己主義なんですね 自己主義だからけしからんだとか
そんなことを言うのは無意味なんです
なんであなたはわがままですか？と言うのは無意味なんです
なぜならば 当たり前でしょうと
それは自然法則だよと
生命は自分のことしか考えられないんです
で 例えば私があの人うるさいんですよと戒めなくちゃいけないんだというのは
自分の心から出てくる素晴らしい慈悲の心
仏様の心じゃないんです
あれはわがままなんです
なぜかというと 私から見たあの人がうるさいんです
私から見たあの人が面倒くさくてややこしいんです
それで戒めなくちゃいけないんだ
それは私が見て考えることなんですね
ですから 他人にとってはすごい大きなお世話なんですけど
それでその人がこの自己主義を
何といいますか 色を塗って
やっぱりそういうふうな人々がいると社会に迷惑ですよと
みんなにみんなのためを思って
その人を厳しく戒めなくちゃいけないんだと
自分勝手にまあ先生になってしまって教えようとかね
指導しようとか何とかする
でもそんなことはお釈迦様の教えから見ると
なんかおかしいんじゃないかと
おかしいということはよく見えるんです
なぜならば そういう人に人を戒めようと
人にちゃんと道徳を教えてあげようではないか
社会を直そうではないかと思う人々は
みんな嫌われちゃうでしょうね
なんで嫌われるんですかね
せっかくいいことをしているんだったら
それは結局自己主義から出てくるんですね
あれは自分のために で
もっとわかりわかりやすい例を出しましょう
小さな子供たちがいる家がある場合は
子供たちがものすごいもう大きい声を出し遊んでいるんだと
で 母親の調子がいい そこで母親が本読んだり
他のことを料理を作ったりしていますし
その間は子供はうるさくてあっち走ったり
こっち走ったり 喧嘩したり
すごい大騒ぎして遊んでいる
そこでその母親はなんとも言わないんですね
すごい気持ちよくて あ
私の子供たち 3人が元気で頑張って遊んでいるんだと
そこで見てください その母親も疲れてストレス溜まっちゃって
ちょっと機嫌が悪くなる
機嫌が悪くなったらどう言いますか？ああいう風に大騒ぎして遊んでいる子供たちに
あんた方はいい加減にしなさいと
静かにしないんですかと
遊ぶんだったら それなりに静かに遊びなさいとか
偉そうに子供たちに説教するんです
勉強で見せたらどうですかとか
そんな風に遊びばっかりしてたら
あんた方はろくな人間になりませんよとか言うでしょ
その時はそれは事実です
だから結局 母と子の関係っていうのは
まあ我々は当たり前で愛情でできてるんだというんだけど
まあ心理から見れば単なる自己主義でできているものなんです
母親の調子がいい時は
子供たちはふざけて遊んでも OK だ
元気でいいんだと 母親も疲れて調子が悪くなっちゃったらしっかりしなさいと言うんですね
そこでちゃんと子供たちに道徳を教えているんだと
生き方を教えているんだと母親が思ってるんです
その思っていること自体も大変誤解なんです
で そう言ったのは やっぱりかわいそうに
生命っていうのは自分のことしか考えることは不可能になっているんです
そういうわけで 悪口で言うならば
まああの なんとかあの
疑詮という言葉がありますね
疑詮 世の中にあるこの道徳やら
ああだこうだとか まあどうかなとちょっと疑う
疑いたくなるんです 疑詮ではないか
で 私は小さい時からもうすごいへんてこりんなことしか考えませんだから
まあ小さい時からこれは疑詮だと思っていたんです
思っていて いかにまあ自分一人だけど
それも自分のことかもしれませんだけど
疑詮にならないかと それは一生の宿題として考えてきたんです
どうすれば自分の心は疑詮にならないかと
そこで出てきた答えは黙っていればいいんだと
できるだけ なぜならば
何か言ったらおそらく私が嫌だから言っている可能性もあるし
ですから 人に何か言う場合は
もう僕は何回も考えて
言うべきか 言うか言うまいか
言うか言うまいかと考えて考えて考えて
そこで自分にとってはもう 90%ぐらいは
まあ別に自分には問題ないんだと
その人は何やっても でも客観的にその人のことを考えちゃうと
これは教えてあげた方がいいと明確にわかったところでだけ言うんです
これはやめなさいと そうでない限り
いくら見えても知らんふりしています
なぜかというと いちいちそれは
例えば電車に乗った人がすごくうるさく
いろんなことを あんたうるさいですよと言えないんです
酔っ払った人なんかかかってくるわ
それで あんた酔っ払って行儀が悪いぞ
しっかりしなさいとは言えないんです
なぜならば その人かかってくると私に迷惑だから
それは私のために そのあんたしっかりしたっても
その人すごい気持ちよくいるんだからね
わからないんですね  そういうことで
あまりそんなこと言ったっても話が逸れますので
生命が我儘でできていますと
そこで自分のことしか知らないんだから
生命には世の中のことを知るはずの筋もないんです
自分のことしか知らないし
自分のこともしっかり知ってないし
ヴィパッサナー実践でもしてない限りは
自分の心は見えません
なぜならば 怒った人は怒って当たり前と思う
人をぶん殴った人はぶん殴って当たり前だと思う
人を貶した人は人を貶す
それは当たり前だと思う
あ 貶してはいけないんだ
それで良くないんだと思って貶す人がいませんね
やっぱり人を殴ってはいけません
それは良くない病気だと言ってぶん殴るということは絶対ないんです
やっぱりこの人をぶん殴らなくちゃいけないんだと思って殴っちゃうんです
ですから 世の中の人をけなすことやら怒ることやら批判することやら
殴ることやら蹴ることやら
何だかんだでも そのやる人がそうしなくちゃいけないんだと
それでいいんだと思ってやっているんです
それで私が言いたいのは
ですから この人間には自分の感情やら感覚やらいつでも正しいんです
この怒りは良くないというのは
ものすごい偽善でインチキなんです
嫉妬するのは良くないと世の中で言うのは
あれはもう完全たる偽善でインチキなんです
わかってないんです で
自分がじゃあ怒るのはいけないという
あなたはどうですか？と言ったら
たまたま怒りますよで
そのなんでたまたま怒りますか？と聞いたら
やっぱり人はいけないことをやったりすると
まあ私は怒りますと その場合は
その本人が自分を怒ることを正しいと正当化しているんです
ということは 世の中でどんな人でも
自分が怒るときは自分が正しいと思っている
自分が嫉妬するときは
それは正しいと思っている
自分が人と喧嘩を売るときは
それまた正しいと思っている
それで人が喧嘩すると
それは自分に迷惑な場合は
喧嘩はいけませんと説法する
だからそれ 偽善でしか何もないんです
だから自分のために 自分の迷惑になると
そういうものは全部いけないと道徳的にいろいろ喋る
聖書から引用するは お釈迦様の経典からも引用するは
どこからでもその言葉は引用する
でも同じ間違いが自分がやるときは平気でやるんです
そこは理解してほしい
それこそ真理なんです
世の中にそういうふうに明確に
堂々と真理は言わないかもしれません
いろいろもう言えない条件もありますから
まあ一応まずそのポイントを覚えておいてください
生命がは えーと 何て言いますか
自己主義であるということ
自己主義のようにできているんだと
そこで 私にとっても生命に悪口を言うことは不可能
できない なぜかというと
私にしたっても 皆さんにしたっても
そういうふうにできているんです
見るのは私であって そこで見たものは私の心の中で自分なりに判断する
聞くのは私であって 聞いた私が私の心の中で自分にできるだけできる範囲で判断する
それに判断して 自分が考えたり喋ったりする
そういうわけで 我々の知識自体
考え方 理解自体も まあ主観的なシステムでできているんです
そこで放っておけば みるみるうちに堕落してしまうんです
ちょっと気をつけて 気をつけて生活すると
世の中のみんな気をつけて生活するでしょ
まあ急に堕落しないだけなんですね
でもじわじわと堕落はするんです
あまり気をつけてない人が一気に堕落してしまっちゃう
急に怒って人を殺したりして
それで全部終わっちゃうとかね
お金ちょっと一束見たところでいいですよと言って何かお酌をしたり
それで全部パーになっちゃうとか
それはあまり気をつけない人々が
ほんで ちょっと気をつける人々が
まあ一応それほど急に堕落はしませんだけど
じわじわときちんと堕落していくんです
そこに出てくる答えがバーワナなんですね
じゃあ心を育ててみようと
心を育てることによって
この自己主義 主観的にしか見られない心に
客観的に見られるように能力ついてあげる
ついてあげるじゃなくて
客観的に見られるように大きく育てる
客観的に物事を見られてしまったら
その人には膨大な智慧があるんです
誰に誰よりも どんな生命よりも
なぜならば一切の生命は主観的だから
で それにバーワナということがするんです
慈悲のことも一つのアヌッサティでもありまして
慈悲のことをパーリ語でメッターアヌッサティというんです 4
つあります メッターアヌッサティ
このメッターっていうのはどうやって出てきましたか？というのは
ちょっとあの言葉分けてみましょうか
慈悲はメッターで それにアヌッセティという言葉をつなげるんです
アヌッセティっていうのは繰り返し念じるという意味なんです
そこであのえ あ  2つついてるんだから一つ落としてつなげちゃうんです
で こちらメッターとあがありまして
こちらアヌッセティとあがありますから
このあ一つ落とす 落としてこのようにつなげる
つなげてメッターアヌッセティと言うんです
ですから 慈悲を繰り返し繰り返し念じるという意味なんです
じゃあそれであの問題に
まあ本格的にこれから問題問題に入ります
で この慈悲の瞑想して
それは主観的に見ると
私は幸せでありますようにと
そうするとそれは結局自分のためであって
まあわかりやすいことで
で あるいは私の親しい人々の願うことは叶えられますようにとかね
思っちゃうと まあ主観的に見る見るととんでもない欲望で
とんでもないやつらなんです
でもそういうことでその言葉ができてないんです
それは心を育てることであって
主観的に世の中を見て
あんたしっかりしなさい
あんた頑張りなさいとかいう態度じゃないんです
それで私の親しい人々の願うことは叶えられますよと
あんた方はもう今は仕事もすごくできて
いいマイホーム建てられて
あのいい結婚相手見つかって
元気に頑張ってください
そういうふうな自分主義
主観 自分中心的な 自分の希望的な欲望の考え方ではないんです
僕は何回もいろんな文章で書いては
まあ喋ってはいたんだけどね
書いてるテキストにその気持ちが入ってるかどうか分かりませんだけど
大体本当のことを言うと嫌われるんだからね
そこら辺なかなかもう入ってないんです
じゃあ今日ももう一回言います
この慈悲の気持ちで我々心の態度を変えようとしているんです
いわゆる自己主義な心の
いわゆる閉鎖的な心 イントロバートマインド
内に持ち 内に自分のことしか見ない心
エクストラバートというオープンな心にしようとするんです
ですから 私が私の親しい人々の悩み苦しみがなくなりますようにと思ったところで
みんなの悩み苦しみなくなるんだったら
一回だけで十分でしょうに
慈悲の瞑想 それだったら僕らにしたっても
小さい頃からもうやってましたから
でも客観的に見ても 大した変わる
大したことを変わったとはわからないんです
変わったかどうか 願うことは叶えられますようにと思った途端
全部願い事を叶ってしまいました
それで終わりでしょうに
一回だけに一回 願い事は叶えられます
願い事全部叶えられましたと
もうそれからは願うことが何もないんだから
もうだんだん次第で終わりでしょうに
そんなことあったっけ？自分慈悲の瞑想してなかったでしょうに
それはちゃんともう装置の上でやってるんです
ですから このそこで慈悲っていうのは友情
メッターっていうのは友情
友情っていうのは いくらか自己主義の人にいくらか育てやすい感情なんです
友情は まああの慈悲喜捨の言葉
メッターっていうのは
いわゆるフレンドシップですね
友情 この友情という感情をいくらか育てやすい
ですから 必要なのは この心の中でいっぱい友情を溢れるような心があることなんです
そうすると かなりこの心のこの小さなリミットが大きくなるんです
それで この私は幸せでありますように
親しい人々は幸せでありますようにっていうのはもう軽い気持ちなんです
で まあ軽い気持ちぐらいで幸せでありますようにということを思われるし
それは軽い気持ちじゃなくて
ちょっと本気になってみんな幸せだった方がいいんじゃないかと
と みんな友達ではないかというふうな感じを頭に叩いてあげるんです
ですから 幸せでありますようにという欲望ではなくて
みんな友達ではないかと
みんな一緒に生きている仲間ではないかと
私もあなたもまあ仲間でしょうという
その気持ちは自分の心に叩いて
もう教えて教えてあげるんです
強引に だからこの心は頑固で硬くて
内面しか見ていない もう外に開けた心まるっきりない
自分だけということで
徹底的にもう強い殻を作って寝ているんです
ですから 朝から晩までみんな同じじゃない
みんな同じ生きてる仲間ではないかと
すーっと心にも言って
言っていて あまりにも言うと
やがてその心の殻が割れるんです
そういうわけで 念じなくちゃいけないんです
もし思った通りになるんだったら
一生一回だけで十分です
ですから 慈悲の瞑想の狙いは
この心の小さな殻を破ることであって
心の成長 バーワーナであります
それ友情で それは私は友情を表す言葉は幸せでありますようにという言葉で考えているんです
で なんでそういうふうに考えるんですかというと
やっぱり経典でも瞑想をずっと実践した伝統の中で
2500 年間もそういうふうな言葉を使ってわかりやすく心に言ってあげたんです
お釈迦様の口からもサッベーサッターバワントツキタッタ
すべての生命が幸福でありますようにという気持ちを作りなさいというふうに言葉があるんです
ですから 気持ちを具体的にわかりやすく作られるんですね
その代わりに私は友情を育てます
私は友情を育てると言ってみてください
全然効き目がないんです
だからそこら辺は心理学的な世界で
いくら心に暗示かけても
私は友情の感情 友情を作りますと
友情で頑張ります 友情で頑張りますと言っても
うまくいかないと思います
その代わりに 自分会った人には
この人も幸せになってほしいという気持ちが正直に出てきたら
そこにあるのは友情なんです
本物の友情なんです いわゆる幸福であってほしいと
本当に正直にそう思いますかね
必要なのは正直に思われることであって
相手が幸福になったら
ほら 私が念じたんだからお前幸福になったでしょうとかというやり方を考えている
私感じます なんか人にちょっとしたいいことをしてあげて
どうですかねという感じで
あんなものは気持ち悪いだけで
私はそういう人々の親切な声も受け入れたくないんです
できるだけ断る それは布施でも親切な行為でも何でもないんです
威張りたくて威張りたくて
どうだい？私はもうあんたを助けてあげたでしょうという感じで
お釈迦様さえそういう人の布施は断る
いりませんと 本当に何もなりませんから
あげたって ですから 世の中では
世の中では人々は人を助けたり
面倒を見たり 心配したりする
そこで面倒を見てもらった方は方々ははい
申し訳ない ありがとうございます
大変ご苦労かけて申し訳ないとか
もう頭を下げて下げて下げて
必死になって感謝しなくちゃいけない
感謝しなかったら そこまでやっているのに
なんだあんたの態度とか何とか
もうこちら側がなんとか気持ち悪いんです
そうすると 助けてあげる側がいい気持ちになっていいんだけど
助けてもらう側の苦しみ考えるんですかね
申し訳ない 申し訳ないと人に迷惑をかけてとか
そんな人助け 人助けでも何でもないんです
助けてもらった方側が何の負担も感じないことこそ自体が助けなんです
例えば私に千円がないと
そして友達がいると でお前
あんた千円持ってるでしょ？ちょっと貸して
何のことなく 貸せない場合は強引にでもちょっとこっちと財布を取って
千円があって これもらったよとかね
それぐらいにすごいお互いもう向こうは怒ったって
本当にもういい もうああだこうだとか言われたって
向こうもあまり気にしないし
こちらも別に気にしないと
その場合は友情なんですね
そこで友達がお願いしますか
手を合わせて千円貸してよと
必ず返しますから お願いします
お願いしますと言うと
無理やりに千円もう貸してあげたところで
それからも感謝して感謝
本当に助かりました ああだこうだとかね
明日必ず帰ります 返しますとか
そちらにあるのは友情じゃないんです
だからこれ バハヴァナだから
そんな簡単にできると私は思いません
かなりきつい修行だと思います
そういうことで この小さな心に友情の気持ちを叩いて叩いて教えてあげて
膨らませてあげなくちゃいけないんです
ですから それ朝から晩までじゃなくて
1週間  2週間じゃなくて
これね 何年でもやらなくちゃいけないんです
やがて心がもう大きい心になるまでは
そういうわけでお釈迦様が推薦している言葉が
あの幸せでありますようにという言葉なんです
ですから それは主観的に見ると
私はあなたが幸せでありますようにと思っているでしょうと
それは瞑想でないと本人が大体わかるんです
わかる人には智慧がある
威張ろうとすると 私は人々の幸せを願っているんだから
かなり聖者だと私なりに立派な人やと思っちゃったら
その人は自分の事 自己自得の法則で
それなりの結果が得られますけど
みんなに嫌われて けなされて
社会から追い出されて
地獄にまで行くかもしれませんだけど
やってるのは口先で幸せでありますようにという瞑想かもしれませんだけど
でも問題は心にあるんだから
行動ではもうわからない
それは上々  2番目に出てくるのは
メッターの次はカルマ
カルマっていうのはバック苦しみを抜く
で カルマにも本当に助けるということなんです
面倒を見る で そこでもあるのは
自己主義なわがままな心は
人の面倒を見たくない
人から何か取りたいんだったら取りますけど
例えば可愛い人だったら親切にする
あまり可愛くないんだ
ちけいという それは人間のやり方なんですね
猫でも犬でもすごい可愛いんだったら
まあ助けたくて助けたくて涙までくるんですね
慈悲の涙が それでその猫をなんかものすごい汚くてボロボロで
もう毛がなくてとかね
あるいは目が 1つなくて
このまあ鼻水が垂らしていると
もうあっち気持ち悪い
気持ち悪いと そういう人間でしょうに
すっごい可愛く可愛い猫やら犬だったら
もうかわいそうですね
この猫を猫を野良猫にしてしまってね
やっぱりちゃんと餌をあげなくちゃいけないと
ああだこうだと これは動物愛好家になっちゃうんです
そこに野良猫が目が 1つない
怪我して喧嘩して ここら辺傷だらけで
それまた化膿してまた花
猫っていうのは鼻水が出始めたら随分気持ち悪いんです
だから私はもう知ってるんだから言ってます
それで毛ももうあっちこっち抜けてしまっちゃって
ボロボロでだったらどう？あの感じは
その時人間っていうのは大体そんなもんなんです
可愛い子供を見たら ああ
可愛い可愛いと すごく憎たらしい子を見たら
もう本当にうるさいんだからと
あんまりにもひどいでしょう
我々の心っていうのは
ですからありえないんです
人の面倒を見たがる こういう気持ち
生命の面倒を見たがる気持ち
苦しんでいる人を見たら
やっぱりかわいそうですよ
なんとかしましょうと
いわゆる他人を見たらかわいそうですよと思えること
はないでしょうに もともと
それで面倒くさいと 何と言いますかね
自分の家でお母さんが
お父さんが おじいちゃんがおばあちゃんが病気になったら面倒くさがるんだから
まあ嫌ですねとかね 病気になって倒れちゃってとか
恐ろしいでしょうに それでよく生きてるんだから
今日も電車で若い女の人が
まあなんか最近流行ってるかどうか分かりませんだが
電車に乗ってからお化粧すると
昨日見ましたと 今日見ましたし
だから世の中の見せろ
どんな酷い顔がこれいろいろペンキ塗って見えるようにするかということは
私も駅で見てるんですよね
あんまりにもバカバカらしいんだから
やることね 家でやってればいいのに
やることが まあそれはどうでもいいんだけど
あので 女の子 2人がなんとかにもうお化粧しながらなんか話になって
親父 これ このイントネーション
僕は気になった そのイントネーションなんです
自分のお父さんもまあバカにしたりいろいろするのは
それはまあ親子間で別に愛情ないわけじゃなくて
愛情あるんだから喧嘩したりするんで
それはわかりますけど
なんかすっごいなんか気持ち悪い
まあ居座っていう感じで
これ自分をずっと抱っこして
もう面倒見て 可愛い可愛いと育てた自分もお父さんに対してでしょうに
私 ちょっと飛んだところで
ああ あの親父かという感じで
気持ち悪いじじいやという感じで
そんな風に思うんだから
この人間の形をとってもいて
だからいくらおけつだっても
僕にはもう醜い顔しか見えないんです
心は醜いんだから で 女の子はあ
お父ちゃん お父ちゃんのことかと言っちゃうと可愛いでしょうね
というと 自分の自分がいくら年取ったっても
自分の父さんの方をお父ちゃんと呼べるような
この愛情っていうのはないでしょうね
自分のお父さんにしても
それぐらいわがままで
それぐらい醜くて と心で人間できているんです
それ私は批判的に言うんじゃなくて
自然にそうできているんです
テレビでインタビューすると
あんた一番嫌いな人は誰ですか？って言ったら
僕はもう一回見たんだけど
なんて母親です 冗談じゃないですよね
母親がなかったならば
あの女がそこにいるんですかね
何から何まで教えてあげて
やっと育てて一人前にしたところで
またふざけて遊びまくっちゃいたいんですよ
世の中に入って それは母親を心配しているんだから
いちいち言うかもしれませんし
子供は母親にいちいち言われたっても
隠れてこそこそと逃げていくのは
それはそれで構いませんだけど
あの態度なんですかね
別に私は反対しませんよ
母親に隠れて どうかちょっとコソコソと逃げて遊んだりしたりするなんか
それはもう若いんだからしょうがないんだけど
もう母親もだいたいそれぐらいのこと知ってるし
知ってるんだけど どうぞ行って遊んでこいとは母親としては言いにくいことなんです
だからなんとかなんとかうるさく言う
それで違うけど なんだかいろんなことうるさいんだと
小遣いはもう足りませんと
どれぐらいあればもう月 2 万 3
万とか言うんですね それぐらいお金払うことできれば
どんな母親でもあげますよ
別にあげないんだったら
それぐらいの事情があるからでしょうね
それぐらい自分の家庭の経済事情さえ理解していない自分だけと
で そういうことで我々は何が理解できるかというと
心っていうのは自分のことしか見ない
恐ろしい 醜い 臭い心なんです
だから人の面倒を見るっていうことも
あり得もないことで あり得もないことで
これはしないんです そこでこの友情よりはやりにくい
カルマが そこで人の苦しみ
人の悩み 問題を見て ああ
やっぱりこれは直してほしいと
この人は悩みのないようになってほしいと
一生懸命子供が受験勉強すると
心の中でああ この子大変苦労しているんだと
うまく合格してほしいと
というふうに思うことを正直に思われる心育てる
そういうふうに育てると
あの小さな心がどんどん大きくなって
限りない大きな心 主観的に心は無量の客観的な心になるんです
というのはもう理屈であって
論理であって 実行しなきゃ意味がないんです
ですから 朝から晩まで心にこのカルナの感情
バックの感情を教えてあげるんです
それであのこちらの瞑想文句は
悩み苦しみがなくなりますようにという文句なんです
で 悩み苦しみがなくなりますようにという文句で
それは正直に心に言っていてあげると
これ 具体的に人の悩み苦しみはなくなる
私は念じたんだから あなたもう悩みないでしょうとか
そんな状態にはならないんです
なったならば あれは瞑想にもならないんです
例えば ある人が自分の友達が大変困っている
そこである友達があ 私の友達の悩み苦しみがなくなりますようにと念じたと
そこでなくなったと すると瞑想にならない
そんなことは ですから
そういうふうにわがままの希望ではなくて
自分が本当に人の悩み苦しみに心配するものかと
人の悩み苦しみを見たら
本当にそれは理解できる
同感できる 感じられる
他人の苦しみ 人間になってますか？ということは心の成長
バハナなんです ですから
前説明した醜い臭い 毒しか入ってない心がものすごい大きくなって
美しく光り輝く変わりのある心になったかならなかったかです
ですから 瞑想っていうのは
バハナというのはあくまでも自分の心の状態を言ってるんです
ですから  2番目にあるカルナ瞑想
こちら慈悲の瞑想というのは瞑想 4つなんです
メッターの瞑想 カルナの瞑想
2つ すごい立場も違うんです
3番目にあるのはムディターの瞑想
ムディターは世の中でどこどれほどないかというと
この 日本語で言葉さえないんです
ですから それぐらい世の中でないものなんです
ムディターの意味は 他人の幸福を喜ぶ気持ち
他人の幸福を喜ぶ気持ち
じゃあ日本語の単語一つ言葉あります
それに 普段言葉にないんです
人間には作っている言葉だから
これ 日本語だけじゃなくて
他の言葉に見ても 他の言語を探ってみたってもね
ない で その代わりに我々は兄弟同士でも一人の兄弟
うまくいっちゃうと もう一人の兄弟は何をするんですか？嫉妬するんです
兄弟同士 それはまあ  兄弟の嫉妬っていうのは変なもので
まあどうにもならないことですけども
喧嘩はするは またどこかでもう互いに心配もするっていう状態もありますけど
やっぱりそれでも明確に兄弟同士で嫉妬することはある場合もあります
一番嫉妬しにくい場所なんです
兄弟っていうのは それでも私はいろいろ人々やら世の中
まあ今までも年はまあ老人になってましたからね
なってますから 見ていたところで
いろんな人に会ってみたところで
やっぱりこの兄弟同士でなんという嫉妬だと
一人が豊かで幸福で成功して
一人が成功していないと
もう仲良くしない いろいろあります
たまにこの豊かな人が
もうあいつらもうけしからんの人だからということで追い出す
あるいはそういうあまり幸福でない人から見れば
まあ向こうはもう金持ちで
もうよく偉そうに威張ってるんだから
私は兄弟関係は持ってないんだという場合もあるし
逆にいい兄弟もいますけどね
まあ一人がすごい豊かになっちゃったら
もう一人の兄弟があんまりもうまくいかない
その人のうちにいて 一生懸命その人の仕事を見てあげたり
面倒を見てあげたりとか
まあお世話ばっかりやっているんですね
まあ私にできなくたっても
お兄ちゃんが頑張ってるんだからと
お兄ちゃんの財産を分けてあげようではないかというふうに
そういう素晴らしい兄弟もいるし
兄弟同士で我々は普通は嫉妬する
人が幸福になっちゃうと
うまくいっちゃうと嫉妬するのは普通です
ですから 嫉妬という言葉はありますけど
なんで嫉妬の反対のムディターに言葉がないんですかね
嫉妬の反対の言葉は何ですかと聞いたらないでしょ
辞書に ですから まああるならば
僕は本当に教えていただきたいんで
なぜならばこれからも説法するんだから
そういう言葉ね 日本語言葉を使わなくちゃいけないし
パーリ語だったら これは明確に嫉妬の反対の言葉
ですから このこれ 3番目の瞑想で
これさらにやりにくい瞑想なんです
なぜならば 自分から見ると人々はすごい幸福で成長して
もう成功ばっかりして頑張っている
というと 自然な姿っていうのは
私も頑張らなくちゃとかね
という気持ちは自然な気持ちで
そうすると頑張ったところでうまくいかないとものすごく怒る
なんで私だけ成功しないかと
なんでこいつらばっかりもう何やってもうまくいく
私は何やってもうまくいかないんだと
なんというひどい人間かと
自分に対してでも怒るは
他人に対して嫉妬するはっていうのは自然的な心の流れなんです
ですから この瞑想の順番で 3番目というのはもっとやりにくいこと
人が幸福になってしまったら
ああ よかったよかったと
その人の気持ちを理解する
楽しい幸福です ああ あんた幸福で幸せで本当すごいよかった
お祝いする このお祝いの気持ちですね
もしかすると嫉妬の反対の言葉はあまりぴったしじゃないんだけど
お祝いかもしれません
ということよね ですから
そこも心にない状態 心は小さくて
自分だけ良ければいい
他人が幸福になっちゃうと
さらになんでこの人々だけ幸福ですかという風にすごい嫉妬して
さらに硬くなる そこでそんなものじゃなくて
人々の幸福を感じなさい
で あなたにできなくたっても
あの人は成功して 見てください
すごい良いでしょうと
かっこいいでしょうと
そういうふうに感じられると
その心には主観的な状態が消えて
それはこちらの瞑想文句の中で
それは願うことは叶えられますように
人々に だから人々の願うことは叶えられました状態
これは念じたくないんです
本当は言いたくない でも
その人の頑張っていることをそれなりに成功してすると
その人々はすごく喜ぶんです
自分が何のこともないんです
で それであれを味わってくる
祝福をする気持ちを作る
それで主観的な小さな心
世の中は見えない心がすべてを見える心の心になる
それでどんな生命にも願い事があるんです
お腹が空いたら何か食べたいなということも願うことなんです
そこで汚い醜い願い事もありますけど
そんないちいちいちいち区別するんではなくて
生命として何とかしなくちゃというふうな願うという気持ちがあって
その場でその場で我々
それぞれ人々が努力することを成功してもらいたいと
それはたとえわずかなことであろうとも
成功しないよりは成功した方がいいでしょうし
で 子供子供やらあるおじいちゃんが凧を作って空を飛ばそうとしている
そこでいい年になって
まだまだ凧を飛ばそうとしているんだから
なんとかもっとしっかりしたことをやればいいのではないかとか
わがまま主観的な説教をするんじゃなくて
なんておじいさんですかと
なるそれ見たら おじいちゃん喜んで子供みたいに凧を飛ばそうとしているんだから
飛ばしてほしいなと思っているわけですかね
別に 飛ばったらそのおじいちゃんが飛ばした
飛びましたよとかね 喜んじゃうでしょうし
それでああ みんな幸福で
幸せ感じるんですね それは感じられる心が育ててほしいじゃなくて
欲的で 世の中 あの人々のどんな希望もその通りに叶ってくださいというふうに思ったっても何の意味もないし
だからといって叶うわけでもないし
で 私はまるっきり勉強しないで寝ていると
それでお母さんに頼みます
お母さん 朝から晩まで私の試験が合格しますようにと瞑想してくださいと
合格するわけないでしょ
そんなことやったっても
そういう非合理的な宗教的な教えではないんです
宗教じゃないんだから
そういうふうに言った方が機嫌いいかもしれません
そういうふうに言ってくださいと頼む時もあります
で 僕は断ります で これで心配がなくなります
まあ 4番目だよ とにかく 3番目はノディタ
それは私たちの瞑想文句であるのは
願うことが叶えられますように
4番目はウペッカー これはもっと難しいんです
どれほど難しいかというと
瞑想の仕方が説明している注釈書などにもやり方が書いてないんです
ウペッカーっていうのは
心の主観的な自己主義を全く消えてしまって
生命は徹底的に生命であると平等ですよと
偉い人も偉くない人も
もう別に誰でもない それぞれなりの形をとって生きているだけだよと
ゴキブリはゴキブリの形をとっているわ
人間は人間の形をとっているわ
ゾウはゾウの形をとっているわ
ゾウはだからといって猛獣の王様ではないし
まあ動物はそんな馬鹿なことをしませんだけど
私は王様だよと思う動物はいませんだけど
ゾウは体がでっかいだからもうすっごいいいんです
森の中を歩くとき 見ると
もう誰がいても何のことなく
自分でゆっくりと歩いて
なんか葉っぱとか何か食べて水を飲んで
ゾウが水飲むところに行くと
他の動物はちゃんと道を開けてあけちゃう
なぜなら踏まれちゃったら大変だから
だからってゾウはね まあ軽くても自分の鼻でそこら辺にいる鹿でも虎でもぶん殴ったらどうなるんですかね
死ぬでしょう でも決してそんなことはしない
ですから 人間はゾウを拝んでゾウに学んだ方がいいかもしれません
早いんです お釈迦様は
信仰するの ですから 僕は本当にゾウを見ると感動するんですね
あれほど力あるんだけど
アリ 1匹にも迷惑かけない
そこでヴィパッサナー瞑想で歩く瞑想を教えたっても美しく歩けないのに
象はなんか瞑想もしていないんだけど
歩く時のあの落ち着いている姿
すごい心落ち着くんです
象を見ると だからできれば象を触ったりとかね
見てください それ一緒にいるだけでも心なんかすごい不思議な
この猫をなんか抱っこしたとは全く違うんです
抱っこできませんだからね
また帰る あれほど大きい体なのに
なんか我々そばに行ったっての知らんぷりをしているし
で もうなんか食べ物とかあったら
それはサッと取って食べたりもするし
で なんかすごくいい波動を持ってるんで
とにかく まあそれでこのウペッカーっていうのは
すべての生命が 宇宙の生命は誰でも
まあただ宇宙の生命である
私もたったそれの 1匹だけですよ
誰が偉いが誰が偉くないかとかね
そんなくだらない考えたらまるっきりない
一切の生命を把握できる
ものすごいすごい落ち着いている心なんです
ですから一番レベルが高いんです
で そこで文句がないとこの瞑想できませんだから
悟りの光が現れますよ
すべての生命に一応入れてはあるんです
私は念じたんだからってみんな悟るわけじゃないし
そのその人は頑張らなくちゃいけないし
じゃあだったらなんで念じるかというと
自分にはその気持ち理解できるためなんです
そういうわけで これは心の汚れを消す
わがまま 煩悩 欲望 それは全部自己中心だから
心のこの小さいレベルを破って
原子爆弾かけて それにもう壊しちゃって
無量の状態を作るための
まあ修行方法の実践方法の一つなんです
それで初期のステップなんですけど
時計見なかったんだから
ちょっと話が長くなっているのかな
で あの じゃあそれは自分の心を育てるためかというと
このすごい この まあ大したことないちっぽけなとこもあります
いわゆる我々が希望するところ
例えば慈悲の瞑想をすると
どうしても家庭環境はうまくいっちゃう
会社でもその人には素晴らしく
みんなと仲良くできる
なんか自分にはいろいろ不幸やらひどい目に遭うとか
突然何かあったとか そういう
全くなくなるという結果が出てきます
でもそれはつまらない結果なんです
別に大したことないし
不思議でもないし 母親は自分のために子供にしっかりしなさいといいんじゃなくて
慈悲の心で言うと言わなくたっても
子供はお互いに心理解し合ってうまく育てるんですね
そこはまあ別に不思議でも奇跡でもないんです
そんなにひどく病気になることもなくなっちゃうし
もうたまたま病気になったっても
何のことなく  1 日 2 日でも体が治ってしまっちゃうし
ご飯大量に食べなくたっても
適当に何か食べたくても綺麗に栄養は体が吸収しちゃうし
そういうふうないろいろ徳があるんです
その徳だけ喋って みんな慈悲の瞑想するようにと応援しなさいと言ったっても
本当のレベルとはまた違うんです
それはすごく高いレベルの瞑想なんです
これ 日常生活で表れてくるご利益
そんなものはつまらないんです
別に で じゃあご利益ないかというと
いえ そうじゃない 確実にあるんです
慈悲の瞑想こそご利益あるんです
こう何か念じるとか お祈りするとか
全然そんなものは効かない
そういう特別に念じるんじゃなくて
一般的に慈悲の瞑想すると確実にうまくいくんです
でも ご利益を狙うんじゃなくて
自分の小さな心の制限的な
リミットされている有限的なこの心を無限な心をになるためにある実践方法ですから
この瞑想に特別な名前があります
し 何でしたっけ？無量心という量がない心
パーリ語でアッパマンニャというんです
アッパマンニャ いわゆるバウンドレス
リミットがない 無制限
それは心の状態を指して呼ぶんです
アッパマンニャ瞑想 4つあるんだと
まあそれであの慈悲についてもう一つ質問ありましたけど
このあのエイズやらね
ウイルスやら成長したらゴキブリとか
で ゴキブリは悪いっていうのは人間中心的でしょう
ウイルスが悪いと思うのは人間が正しい
と言うならばウイルスが悪い
人間が正しいというならば
ゴキブリは悪い だからそれこそ慈悲ではないんですね
そういうふうに言えないでしょ
なんでシロアリが悪くて人間は正しいんですか？シロアリが何か悪いことしていますか？シロアリはもうなんかね
木材と木とかね 食べるのはシロアリの食べ物でしょうに
ご飯食べて何が悪いですかに
じゃあ人間がなんでその他の生命を奪って殺して食べてるんですかね
ですから我々は他の生命は理解しない問題なんですね
ですから ゴキブリも幸せでありますようにと念じるのは決して悪くないし
だからって自分の家でゴキブリを育てるなと
それはバカバカらしいんです
はい  先生はそうおっしゃいますけどもね
地球上ではみんながですね
人間こそ最高の王者と思っていますからね
だからそう 先生の前では言わないですけどもね
そう思ってます 霊長の王者だからリーダーだと思ってるんですよね
だから人間 うちでもですよ
人間に邪魔するものは殺せ
ですよね そうですね ですから
この人間だけ そういうおっしゃる通りに
まあ王者という感じが
それ何も証拠もないし
で 自分勝手に それこそわがまま
自己中心的な考え方で無知なんですね
それで大蛇という思ったことでどうなったかというと
人間にも生きていられられないほど
この世の中を我々は壊しちゃったんですね
だから結局我々はゴキブリを殺しちゃったんじゃなくて
自分を殺してるんです
いろんな殺虫剤とかなんとか撒いたところで
魚の体の中で何のことなく
あの 今最近言ってるあの毒物は何でいますか？あのダイオキシンとかね
魚の体の中にちゃんと入っていて
食べてみてくださいと
結局自分たちが毒を作って
自分で食べて自分を殺してるんですね
一緒にすべての生命も殺している
この地球上だけに限ってしたっても
微生物からウイルスからゾウまでもうそれから他
あのクジラとか そういう大きな動物まで
人間はもっと小さいんだからね
ゾウよりは ですから すべての生命をまとめると
水の中だったらクジラまで
陸上だったらゾウまで
すべての生命がお互いにバランスを取っていると生きていられるんです
ウイルスなしには生きていられないんです
ウイルスとそれからいろいろね
まあ細菌の種類あるでしょうに
殺してみて下さい あの小さいワルに結構命を支えているでしょうに
みんな美味しそうに酒飲んでるんだけど
ウイルス嫌いと細菌嫌いと
あんまりにもね 納豆食べてるでしょうに
細菌は嫌いなんだ あれなんですかね
そこでお腹の中に細菌殺してみたら
全部ビタミン失調 失調というんですか
うん そう ビタミンなくなっちゃうでしょうに
このビフィズス菌とまた何かなにかこの細菌があって
それは我々食べた食べ物はちゃんと消化させて
余計なものは全部体から自然に出せるように活性活用してくれるでしょうに
あれほどお世話になっていて
何言うんですかと ですから
このあなたは敵じゃないという気持ちが生まれたら
確実に敵でなくなっちゃうんです
そこで虎っていうのは危ない動物でしょ
じゃあ虎と仲良くしてみてください
飼ってみてください 何のことなく大きな猫だけなんで
その場合は 虎は猛獣だ
人間食って食べるんだとか
そんな怒りのこと言わないで
まあ虎1匹飼ってみたら
あるいはアメリカ人がそういう捨てられる動物を集めていて
ところをテレビで見たんだけど
いろんな猛獣たちがその人を引っ張ってくるんです
で 彼が育てたわけでもないんです
あの虎なんかそこらに平気で行くんですね
虎がその人の体に乗って顔を舐めるは
どんな動物もそんな調子なんで
そこで彼がこのまた法律によっては一つ全部殺さなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんです
それでその思い出すときも
その人は 我々人間が悪いでしょうと
こういう動物を飼って
もう飼えなくなっちゃったら捨てたりして
私は広く扱ったんだ なぜならば人間でそれ責任持たなくちゃいけないんだと
もう野生に戻らないんだと
だからその男が自分と同じ生き物だと見ているんだから
あの虎のライオンたちもワニたちも全く仲間だと思っているんです
ですから すごい 本当にこの王者の感覚を捨てちゃえば
素晴らしい世界が生まれていく
今日私は部屋の掃除かけると昨日見たんだけど
このアリの 4 分の 1 ぐらい小さなもう虫か何か見えない
僕の目が あまりもう最近老眼で良くないんだけど
いることはわかるんですね
で 放っておいて 今日掃除機かけちゃうと
まあこれいるんじゃないんです
畳の上で それで私はもう丁寧に
その虫を吸いされちゃいますから
されないように まあよけてよけて掃除機をかけてるんです
それでも空気が回るでしょ
そこでその小さな まあもしかするとアリかもしれませんだけど
サッサッと逃げて この畳のあの糸のあれ入って
その間にいるんですね
隠れて隠れてないんです
それでも上へ掃除機の頭入っちゃったら全部食いされますけどね
あの瞬間で僕はものすごく可愛いと
この小さな目に見えるほど小さいワニ
あっ 隠れようと 危ないと自分の命を守ろうとしているでしょ
だからもう顕微鏡 まあ虫眼鏡あったら何？動物の何虫かとわかるかもしれませんだけど
あの ちょっと あの ちょっと
あの あの なんていうか
糸を通っているところ
ちょっと下に入ってる
こういうのはちょっと温めに波みたいなところありますからね
そこに行ってこうやって待ってるんです
そこで一応掃除機かけたところに逃げちゃったんだから
私にとっても大変楽に掃除機かけられるし
で その瞬間ですごく私が喜びを感じたんです
あれは正真正銘の一個の生命であって
あれなりに自分を危ない時はもう身を
あの虫にしたらものすごい
なんて言いますか あのアメリカで出てくるあれ
なんて言いますか あのトルネード
竜巻 竜巻みたいな感じでしょうね
だから小さいとはもう貶されませんね
そういうわけで 別にこのエッチはいろいろウイルスは人間に攻撃しません
人間間違えちゃうとそうなるんです
ですから 人間がいろんなウイルスの病気になるというならば
それは我々は自然破壊しているということであって
我々はバランスを崩したということであって
ヘビはダメで ヘビに噛まれたら死ぬよというのは
ヘビがいるところに行って余計なことをするんだからでしょうに
それでどうしても森に入り入りたければ
長靴でも履いて行けばいいでしょうし
そこで片っ端からヘビを潰す必要はないんです
ですから お互いにうまく調和して生活すればよろしいということなんです
一応そこら辺ちょっと休憩して
次に説明いたします 次の説明とは
あの慈悲のことを聞いただけでも
こちらの奥様が聞いたように感動しましたと
普段やらないんだとね
嫌いな人もこう下りますようにと
で まあそういうあの その気持ちが大事なんです
そういう話を聞いただけでも
すごいと感じること そういうことはもう心はなんとなく
あ 小さい心でよくないとことをわかっていることなんですね
ですから そういう風に何か慈悲の言葉を聞いて
なんとなく感動するならば
なんとなく喜びを感じるならば
心は正しい方向へ向いているんです
いわゆる広げる方向になっていることなんですね
であまりこのこれは合理的に論理的に考えても心は育てないんですね
ですから できれば慈悲の瞑想は真実だから合理的に説明できるんです
でも合理と理屈だけでぶん殴っちゃうと
心は感覚的に広げるということはなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜならば すべての論理っていうのは
私がここにて私の知識に基づいて理解するということだから
論理は結局は主観的な意見になっちゃうんですね
ですから 論理抜きに抜きではなくて
論理をちょっと乗り越えて感動するところで
楽で誰にでも実践できるものなんですね
だから 例えば嫌いないこちらのお子様がよく嫌いな人に会うんだと
それはいいことで 嫌いな人だと思ったら
そういう人々も幸福でありますようにと念じられると
そちらは喜びを感じられるんですね
ですから そういう方向で修行しなくちゃいけない
これで嫌と思うんじゃなくて
あ その人は別に私に何かやってるわけじゃなくて
その人は自分の世界で一生懸命頑張ってるんじゃないんですかと
それで私はなんで心が嫌な気持ち作らなくちゃいけないんですかと
それで私が苦労するだけですよと
ですから こういう迷惑な人々の周りにいたっても
それなりに頑張っているんだと
で 元気で頑張ってるんだと言って思ったところで
あ まあ二度と嫌な気持ちが生まれなかった
その人々の気持ちもわかるようになると
ものすごく感動できるんですよ
あの  僕の場合で言うならばね
まあ結構いろんな子供たちに会うんです
会うたびに何言われるかわからないんですね
すっごいもう失礼なことを言う時もあるし
まあいろいろあるんです
で どっちついたって 向こうはこいつら元気で頑張ってるんだという気持ちにしか生まれてこないんですね
ある子供たちはもう危ないんだから逃げろと逃げる場合もあるし
別に僕は食べるわけでもなんでもないんだけどね
それを見たら ああ やっぱり子供やと
子供ですよということで
なんとなくまあかわいいと
そこであるこの間 男 まあ大体男なんかきつく言うのは ３人グループだったらね
で  ３人 ４人だったらもう元気で頑張っちゃいますからね
そこもまたかわいいんです
一人でいると弱いし もう何も相手のことを気にしないんですけど
３人 ４人になっちゃうと
もうなんとかいじっていじめてやろうとか
元気が出てくる そこでいじめたって
僕から見れば あ 子供４人がグループを作って
なんか元気に元気なグループを作ってるみたいということで
まあ楽しくなるだけなんですね
最近である男の３人のグループが
一人がこの頃を見たら
あの子にはなんとなく違う格好だから
すごいもうなんか思ったで
そこでかっこいいと言うんですね
あの子はかっこいいと言ったんなら
まあその子にはかっこよく映ったかもしれません
もう３人も同じことはかっこいい
かっこいいって言うんで
そこで僕に見えるのは
まあ一人にはこの子もかっこよく映った
そこであの３人がただそれに引き摺られて
もうなんとか言わなくちゃ
いたずらしなくちゃいけないんだから
この男のグループだから
ただかっこいい かっこいいと言ってるんだと
そこを見たら あ 子供たちのやり方ですよというぐらいのことで
で 今日来るとまた３人のグループなんですけど
女の子２人とちっちゃな男の子
同じ家族じゃないんです
それは仲間にならないんです
女の子２人と男の子だから
で 男の子は何のこともなかったんで
女の子ちっちゃな２人が変な人というんですね
別に まあそれでこの女の子２人から見れば
これ変な格好だから変な人ですよと
それだけのことで それでもその２人がかわいいと
で まあもし喋る状態だったらなんとか一言言ったってもいいんだけどね
別にまあそんなこと気にしないで
僕はまあずっと できるだけ早く行くと
行くと捕まれたら大変なんですからね
まあやっぱり 4人以上いるんだったら
できるだけ僕は足が早いんです
3人以下だ  3人か4人以下だったら別に普通に歩けますけど
4人以上だったら子供たちに捕まっちゃうんです
怖いと思え 思おうか 変な人だと思うか
もう捕まってなんとかなんとかしちゃうし
そこで僕は一応もう接する方法を知ってるんだから
もうすぐもう仲良くなって
肩に乗っていろいろこれも引っ張ったりいろいろするんだから
昔いろいろ大変なことにひどい目にあったんだから
もうできるだけ逃げる
だから僕から見れば 嫌だから逃げるんじゃなくて
こいつらに捕まらないように逃げろと
ただ 気持ちとしてはもう可愛いという気持ちしかないんですね
ですから まあそういうふうに育てた方がいいと思います
我々にこの自分の希望通りに好ましい人間ばっかに会うように世界はコントロールできない
世界にはいろんな人がいるんですからね
で 私たちにできるのは
私たちが心を汚さないように
汚れないようにすること
で 感動する方向へ持っていけばいいんです
慈悲の気持ち うん じゃあ
それで慈悲についての問題終わります
それからまた後で聞いて思い出したんだけど
あの慈悲喜捨というのは
このメッタカルナムディタウペッカーっていうのは4種類の瞑想
どんな瞑想でも 心の主観的な小さな心が広げて無量の心が生まれる
ですから 人は 4つも修行する意味がないんです
無量な心だけ作っていただければいいんです
ですから 自分たちにピンとくる
どんなこの 4行の中で 1つ必ずあるはずなんです
メッターかムディターかカルナかウペッカーどっちか
いわゆるこの皆様に教えられている 4行の中で
もう納得いける行  1文句はあるはずなんです
4つも納得いかなくても
その納得いく感覚を感情を育てればいいんです
最初はまあ 自分の心の状態
どっちかわからないんだから
4つも念じてみます そこでまあ 1行はもうちんとピンとくるんだというならば
それだけで瞑想続ければいいんです
やりやすい順番で言えば
メッタカルナムディタウペッカーですね
一番最高な瞑想というならば
ウペッカーなんですね
あの 何も特別な感情感覚なく
すべての生命はまあ上もなく下もなく
みんな生命やっていう感じで
いることは一番素晴らしいことで
それでいろいろ禅定作ることもできるし
じゃあ次の どんな順番でいいんでしょうかね
じゃあ短くして答えます
あの人は生きることは一生懸命なんですけど
なんで生きることには飽きませんか？という質問がありました
そこで私に簡単にすばりと答えるのであれば
なんででしょうかねと
というふうに それ発見しなくちゃいけないんですね
ご自分で それもやっぱり
それはまあ正真正銘の仏教的な質問で
あの 仏教を勉強すると
だいたいそういう問題は出ます
なんで飽きないんですか？と
生きることには飽きることなく
一生懸命なんですけど
そこをそれこそがあの
我々は発見するんです
なんでそんなに必死になって生きていきたくなるんですか？と
で まあ答えがあるんだけど
答えを言っても ただそういう答えですかと
知ってるだけで意味がないんですけど
ですから この自己観察によって
なんで自分が飽きませんかと
とにかく何かにして生きていきたいとという気持ちは
なんで自分にあるかっていうことは
自分の心を見ると見えてくる
もしそういう何かことを大事なことを発見すればそれでいいし
無意味だと発見すればそれはそれでいい
で 仏教の答えっていうのは
やっぱり渇愛ですね 渇愛という
この欲という働きがあります
で 欲と言ったっても その場合は一般的な意味で欲というんですね
欲しがるということで
まあ渇愛というんですね
ですから で なんで渇愛が生まれるかというと
すべては不完全なんです
すべて不完全で消えちゃうんです
無常だから だからすごい不満が生まれる
不安 心配感が生まれる
生きる場だから生まれた瞬間からも
そのできた細胞自体も弱くて
すぐ壊れそうで ちょっとしたことで死んでしまう
だからもう大変 だから必死になって守ろうとする
自分の命をなぜ守ろうとするんですかというと
それは殺す 殺そうとしているからなんです
なぜ我々は部屋に鍵をかけますかというと
泥棒が物を取ろうとしているんだからなんです
まるっきりどこにも泥棒がいないと思ったら
別に鍵をかける必要はないんですね
そういうことで すべて無常だから
消えるんだから もうなんか捕まってもらってほしがっちゃうんですね
その気持ちに渇愛というんです
ですから不完全だから何やっても足れないんですね
例えば美味しいご飯を食べようと思って
頭の中で妄想するんで
美味しさは でも実際に食べている物質的なご飯は不完全なものなんです
ですから 食べてももうちょっと美味しかった方が良かったんではないかという気持ちが生まれるんです
そこでまた食べたくなる
お金が儲かっても それで十分ということにならないんですね
それでお金儲かったお金も消えていっちゃうし
それでできることも少ないし
そうするともうちょっとあった方がいいと出てくるんです
それはお金が入っても
それは不完全であって
無常だから消えるんだからそうなっちゃうんです
ですから 我々に健康があっても
もうちょっと健康的であった方がいいという気持ちが生まれる
なぜならば 今の健康状態は不完全なんです
ですから ずっと我々はこの不完全な不完全ということで
もうすごく攻撃されているんです
そこでもうしょうがなく
欲が生まれてくる 渇愛が生まれてくる
それで間違っている方向で頑張っちゃうんです
いわゆるお金が不完全だから足らなくなっちゃうんです
もっと儲かっても足らないんです
ご飯食べて美味しかったんだけど
もっと美味しいものを食べたいという気持ちになる
それで何を食べても同じ気持ちなんですね
もっと美味しいものを食べたいんだと
ですから 生きることでいくらひどい目にあっても
もうやっぱりそれだったら違うことをやりましょう
ゴールデンウィークで
例えば今年沖縄に行って
あまりにも暑くてひどい目に遭ったならば
もう二度とゴールデンウィークはやりませんという気持ちにならない
ならないんですね じゃあそれだったら来年北海道に行こうということになっちゃうんです
沖縄に行って もう暑くてしょうがなかったんだから
じゃあ沖縄に行こうと
沖縄じゃなくて北海道に行くことになっちゃうんです
それで北海道に行った
見たところで 北海道は綺麗なのは冬なんですね
夏は別に大したことないんです
ああ これつまらないと
と じゃあそれで今度はまあじゃあ再来年は他のところという風になっちゃうんです
ですから それはものは不完全であるから
無常だから出てくるもので
無常なものはいくら広げても無常ですよ
だから壊れるものはいくら集めても壊れるんです
それは避けられないんです
ですから あ なるほど いくら集めても壊れるんだということは
理解することは仏教とは違う道だと
反対の道だというんです
そこに目が覚めてくれない限りは
解脱の方向へ行かないし
それでもう初めて生きることに飽きるんです
生きることに飽きるということは
仏教で言えば悟りの智慧なんですね
だから悟ってないということになるんですね
悟っている人だけ飽きるんです
ですから これも一つの普通の人間持っている生命
持っている感情なんです
だから動物見たっても
本当に何やってるか バカなことばっかりやっているでしょうに
我々よりね 命が短い動物は観察できるでしょう
一生懸命子育てするわ
もう喧嘩しながら子供を守って
もう命かけて それで子供が大きくなっちゃうと追い出しちゃって
それ自分たちが年取って死ぬ
ただそれだけ その子供また相手見つかって交尾して
また必死になって子供育てて
もう餌を運んで運んで
もう同じことを でもその動物にはそれ見えない
何のためにあんた方はこんなやってるんですか？と
何か目的もありますか？と
何もないんだけど やるんです
だから一生だからわからない
我々にとって一生だからね
子供育てて子供を大きくして終わっちゃうと一生終わってるんです
そこでまあ これの人生何もなくて
ただ墓穴していて死んでしまっちゃうんです
何のために生きてきたんですか？っていうことは
もうもう何もないんですね
ですから まあなかなか気がつかない
そういうことで この真理を見ると
無常であるということはわかると
違う次元の智慧と智慧っていうものが生まれてきて
あ 無意味だと 生は苦であるということは
苦っていうのは無意味ということなんですね
で わかって飽きちゃうんですね
その飽きることは決して否定的なネガティブな感情ではなくて
大変高度な智慧なんです
以上です で 次の質問に行きます
次 あの瞑想の問題でしたから
サティの 質問で このパティパダに出て出た質問はどなたが聞いたことかわかりませんだけど
そういう質問がありまして
ちゃんとこのプロセスをヴィパッサナーの
教えてくれるんだったら
しっかり自信があって瞑想できるんだと
で そのプロセス言うこと自体
ヴィパッサナーでは無意味なんです
修行者に そういうふうにできているんです
でも 質問されたら答えなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 僕はこの本人がもし真面目に修行するならば
その修行に立ち触れない
邪魔に邪魔にならないように
まあちょっと納得したような誤解が生まれるように
で答えたんですけど 大体この厳密に質問する人々には
もう厳密に答えない方が答えない方が納得するんです
知識っていうのはそんなもんなんです
ある昔 私は国で教えていた時は
この高校で教えている先生たちのセミナーがあって
で 彼らに 2 日間休みを有給休暇もらって
このセミナーに参加して
ちゃんとハンコを押してもらわなくちゃいけないんです
で まあ僕は仏教専門の方でしたから
この高校で向こうは仏教目一つの科目になっているしね
まあ選択科目で そういう方々に教える先生たちが
まあみんなその勉強してる人々
専門でやっている人々なんです
たくさん集めているんです
そこで このセミナーに行って話す
話してくださいと まあ私たちにも
まあもう大学でもあんた来なさいと言われちゃって
で行かなくちゃいけない
行ったんですね 行ったら私は年下で
笑 で この方々はもうかなりもう学校でね
まあ何か教えているんだから
みんな年上なんです 同じ大学を卒業した人々にしたって
みんな先輩たちなんですね
ほとんど誰の顔もわからない
僕も その先生たち 私を見たら
まあなんかどっかのガキが来たんじゃないかなと思ったでしょうね
それで私も態度あまり良くないし
もう分厚い本やらテキストやらファイルとか全然持っていかない
どこに行っても この大学で講義するときは
いろいろファイルとかもちゃんと整理しておいたんだけど
まあそれはもういろんなことを教えていたんだから
自分の頭混乱しないようにちゃんと整理して
あの言葉を忘れる時とかね
メモを持って行ったんだけど
普通の場合はもう何も持っていかない
それでまあ どこら辺の若い坊さんたちはあちこち遊び回ったりするんだから
そんな感じでもう何のことなく行ったんです
なんか道が迷子になって間違って入ったような感じで
場所にに入ったんです
で 入って  それ特別特別この文部省で管理しているんです
向こうの だから文部省の人々が知ってるし
で 彼らが案内して それでいて
座ったらみんな態度が良くない
そこで講義始めたら まあ私は何のことなく
まあ冗談に言いながら
もうもうこうやって まあこういうことですよとか喋ってるんです
で 必要なことはどんどんどんどん言うんですけど
言って時間にぴったし止まって
そしたらいきなりある先生があんた何のこともなく
まあ見ただけであんた全然準備していないと分かりましたけど
なんかすごく腹立ってるんですね
もうガキだと思って あの全然準備してないと分かったんだけどね
そういうふうに言ったって
我々は実際に現場で高校生に教えているんだからね
そういうふうには教えられませんと
今言ったもう彼らは知らないポイントをたくさん言ったんです
これからそれを教えなさいと
そういうことを教えなかったら
もう次の大学受験っていうのは
向こうは国家試験で 次の受験ではみんな落ちるんだと
質問作るの僕らですからね
また大学でこう作ってるんだから
それにちゃんと準備してもらわないとね
学校で  そういうふうに言ったっても
まあどういう敵 最後に聞いたのは
もう何かって どんなテキストにその言ってることは書いてるんですかと
聞いたら 僕ら本当のことを言うと
僕は一つのテキストじゃなくて
ありとあらゆるテキストの中から
それからまあ現代ヨーロッパ哲学ですか
それと比べて 仏教はヨーロッパ
いわゆる西洋的な教育だからね
そういう風に見られるようにということで
ですから テキスト参考書というのはもう 400ぐらい言わなくちゃいけないんです
そう言ったっても 先生たちにそんなことを読む暇もないし
彼らに必要なテキストはちゃんと作って出してるんです
僕も半分以上それ書いてあったんです
だからそちらにあるんだから
別に で どこにどんな参考ですかと
特別なポイントとして
僕はじゃあこの人に全く違うことを言ってやると
どうなるかと 自分もちゃんとパーリ語で調べる
大学で 3年やってきましたよと
だから僕は全然関係ないテキスト
まあ同じパーリ経典なんですけど
関係ないテキストの まあこういうところを見てくださいと
そちらにありますよと
これ試しに聞いたんです
そしたらきちんとテキスト言ったら
ああそうですか 分かりました
座っちゃうんで でもかわいそうなんですね
本当は彼がそんなに知ってる人だったら知るはずなんです
そこら辺にはそんなことないんですよと
知って え？そこら辺にはそんなことないんです
私も読みましたよと言ったならば
もう大丈夫でしょうし
それだったらね で 僕はまあ実はそうですと
で そうではなくて まあこういうこういうそれで教える気持ちが出てくるんです
本人知ってるんだから
テキスト まあこういうこういうテキストに
こういうこういうふうに読んで
こういうことを言いましたと言えるし
まあそうですかと言って納得して座りましたから
笑いもんですけどね   そういうことで
この僕は言いたがっているのは
このあまりにもこのきちんと順番で教えてくださいと言っても
まあそれは良くない時もあります
だからこの明確にはちょっと言ったら困るというところはあります
そこで私が困るんじゃなくて
修行する方々の修行の妨げになるんですね
一応それでも順番はいくらかこういうふうにありますよと
あのミャンマーの瞑想法っていうのをテキスト見ても
一応ヴィパッサナーはどのように続けていくかということは書いてあるんです
でもそういうのはほんのわずかで
それよりそのヴィパッサナーの智慧の成長過程のもうもう理解できないほど
もう膨大な世界なんです
そういうわけで 私は書いたのは
ヴィパッサナーのサティの入れ方さえ間違えなければ困る必要はないんだと
自然に心が育てていくんだと
だから今日 この質問に答えて言えるのは
このサティの間違わない入れ方は何ですかと
そこをまた大変な問題なんです
ですから この一応言葉でこう覚えておいてください
客観的な見方だよ ただ見るだけですよと
見て判断するものではないんだと
それは正しいサティの入れ方なんですね
客観的に見る 見たものについて判断はしないと
あるいは見るだけです
確認するだけですと それだけ覚えておけば間違わないんです
そこでいろんなこのこのあるそれぞれの個人にいろいろトラブルが現れるんです
そのどんなトラブルが現れても
綺麗にそれは乗り越えていくことはできるんです
このトラブルってどういうものかというと
このサティの入れ方ははっきり言うと最初から間違っているんです
私が言う私ではなくて
この瞑想法で このミャンマーの瞑想法で言っていること自体も
最初から間違っているんです
僕らの国ではもうちょっと違う方法でやりますけどね
それはもうちょっと厳しいと思います
それで この何が間違っているかというと
例えば膨らむと膨らみ縮みと
まあ言葉で確認してるでしょ？左足上げます
運びます 下ろしますと
でも最初はそうするしか方法ないんです
そこで左足上げます 運びます
下ろします とかやっていると
どんどん集中力が出てくる
集中力が出てくると 今まで見えなかったものも見えてくる
今まで体験できなかったことも体験できる
それでそれもちゃんとノーティンですか
確認する作業をする それで最初から私にそれ言えないんです
ですから とりあえず左足上げます
運びます 下ろします ってやってください
やって落ち着いてみてください
そこで落ち着いてきて
集中力が出てくると それだけじゃなくて
他の様々な体の感覚もにも気づくんですね
気づくものもちゃんと確認して確認していくんです
それでこの進めるはずなんです
たとえ膨らみ縮みを見てくださいと言ったら
ガンコと膨らみ縮み見るだけではなくて
最初はそれさえもできないんですね
でもどんどんそれ見えてくる
それでいろんな感覚が生まれてくる
それも確認していく そういうふうに
このやがて言葉っていうのは全く追いつかない状態になるんです
なぜかというと 人間の経験すべてに言葉を作ってないんです
言葉は大雑把な荒っぽい経験にしか出てこない
出てないんです 例えば足というんだけど
足って何ですかね 実際に
ただ このでっかいこのものに大雑把に足と言うんだけど
足にしたっても また言葉から見て指があるわ
かかとというものがあるわ
ふくらはぎというものは膝ということがあるわ
太ももというものがあるわ
それで腰骨につけているそこら辺もいろいろある
そういうものを別々に感じるようになっちゃうし
結局何なのかという問題に出てくるんです
そこでとにかく集中力が成長すると
どんな言葉でラベリングした方がいいかとわからなくなっちゃうんです
それでも確認して続けなくちゃいけないんです
本人がいつでもこのなんとなく混乱状態にあるかもしれません
明確に言ってはいけないんだけど
とにかく 例えばあまり落ち着きがない人
膨らみ縮みと見ていると
膨らみ縮み見るだけで精一杯
痛みと膨らみ 縮みと音とそれ見るだけで精一杯
精一杯仕事をしたら ああ
よく集中力できたと よく気持ちよくなったとみんな反応するんです
本当はまあヴィパッサナーから見れば
もうほんのわずかな集中力でしょう
で もうさらにその人はいくら気持ちよかったんだから
もっと明確に丁寧に見ようとすると
集中力がもっと育てちゃう
育てたところで膨らみ縮みしたっても
いろんな複雑な行動であることは見えてくる
痛みにしたっても 単なる痛みではなくて
あるわあるわ いろんなものがあると見えてくるでしょう
その見えてくるのは集中力ができているんだからなんです
気がつくのは それで言葉が追いつかない
言葉が追いつかない状態は混乱しましたと
そこでもう 2 3週間やったところでどうですかと言えば
なかなかもう集中力できないと反応するんです
厳しく難しかったと 大変でしたと
本人はそう言うんだけど
こちらから見れば見られているということなんです
大変でしたと きつかったというと
まあ痛くてきつかったというならば
それは簡単なことで そうじゃなくて
別に痛みなかったんだけど
妄想が出るわ 痛みが出るわ
膨らみ違うわ 痺れるわ
ああだこうだとか 音は聞こえるわ
まあ遠いところの音も聞こえるわ
もう感覚は敏感になっているわ
もうどうだ 状態になったというと
その人の観察能力がかなり成長していて
見えすぎ状態になっている
本人がなんか落ち着きがないと感じるだけ
ですから その時でもサティの入れ方の基本を覚えておいて
とにかく確認していくんだと
言葉が追いつかない 追いつかなくなっちゃったら
何でもいいんです その場合は
どんな言葉でもいいんです
言葉なくてもいいんです
できれば言葉ない状態で確認続ければいいんです
それにはすごく智慧が必要なんです
ですから 日本風に言えば
こんな感じ あんな感じですよと確認すればいいんだけど
けど こんな感じ あんな感じだけです
なんかどこかで それも言葉ですからね
今はこんな感じですよと
すぐに違う 今はこんな感じですよと
そんなやり方でもとにかく確認し続けなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで言葉はもう全く追いつかない
いろんなものを見えてくる
次のステップというのは
じゃあその見えてくるものは全部まとめたら
どんな言葉でまとめられますか？そこでやっと仏教の用語が出てくるんです
体で感じるものは全部受で見る
感覚で見る それは種類で
痛みであろうか しびれであろうか
えっとね いろいろまたかゆみであろうか
また 言葉で感じないいろんな感覚はあります
全部体で感じる 感受 受でヴェーデナであると
と一つだけで見られるところまで
一言葉でしか確認できないところまで集中力を育てなければいけない
そこで受だけで見られると
受そのものがもう生滅変化している過程が見えるし
そこで受に基づいて感覚に基づいて自我意識ということができるんだという因果法則がそこで現れてくるのです
そこでこの一つの悟りの過程今言いますけど
そこであ 受こそさえ消えたら
そこに自我がないんだと
例えば受もそれぞれたまに痛み
あ 私が痛いという自我が生まれる
それで気持ちよくなる
あ 気持ちいいという受でしょ
あ 私が気持ちいいという自我が生まれるんだと
私が気持ち悪いという私も
私が気持ちいいという私も違うもんだと化け物だと
その時その時現れるもんだと
受さえなければ何もないわ
わかったぞという気持ちになるんです
それは自分の経験でないと何の意味もないんです
無我だとわかったと そういうふうに悟りに行く人もいるんです
それ一つの道 一般的な道と
またナーマルーパですか
体と心の働きを別々に分かってきて
体は生滅変化していくんだ
心はすごい勢いで生滅変化しているんだという両方わかってきている
そこでもう自然に生滅変化していることを見えていると
集中力が強烈にできたら確認できなくなっちゃう
あまりにも早くて物事が現れてくる
現れるものは何でも見える
わずかなまぶたの感じもわかる
で 心の波も明確に見える
それもう確認できない
サティできない状態になる
それで一言葉にまとめなくちゃいけなくなっちゃう
それで最初は生じて滅するんだとという気持ち
自然に生まれてくる もう面倒くさいんだと
もう何でもすぐ現れて
いろんなこと現れて消えているんだと
その瞬間でものすごい瞬間的なんですよ
すぐにもう面倒くさくて
まあ消えるわ 消えるわ
これも消えて あれも消える
これも消える これも消えるだけに見えてくるんです
それは専門用語でバンニャーナというんです
バンガっていうのは この壊れていくんだい
滅ですね 破壊していくんだと消えていくんだって
ニャーナは智慧ですね
バンガニャーナというんです
ですから このこういう名前には全然意味がないんです
私にバンガニャーナ生まれているんだ
ナーマルーパ分別の智慧が生まれているんだとか何とか
そんな名前あまり意味がないんですけど
とにかく本人にはもう
確認できない 何でも見えるんだけど
見られないほどもう消えては消えるんだ
消えるんだ 消えるんだ
消えるんだ その人 そこでスイッチとした
この感覚が変わっちゃうんですね
瞑想はすごくきついです
その時はすっごいきついんです
でも ものすごく真面目にやらなくちゃいけない
真面目にやりたいんだけど
前と同じく膨らみ縮みとか
そんなゆっくりのんびりないんです
今 初めての方々は膨らみというならば妄想までするんです
余裕がありすぎて あれは集中力ないことなんです
集中力があるとこんな暇はないんです
集中力が出てくると 自分がこの
例えば  1000人が仕事をしている工場で一人で仕事を任せたことになっちゃうんです
全部やらなくちゃいけないんです
結局自分に全部できる
そこである日突然 この 1000人が仕事をした工場で
もうもう 999 人が消えちゃったと
それでも工場はやらなくちゃいけない
そこで自分でみんな来るまで何とかするぞと思って
機械はスタートしてやっちゃうと
やれますかね できるんだけど
でも必死になって その人には妄想でも何でもする暇がないんで
こちらのスイッチを押して
あちらの荷物をこちらに担いで
あっち行ってこれやって
こう忙しいんです それぐらいの気持ちになっちゃうんですね
集中力が出てきたら そこまで瞑想を続けなくちゃいけない
そこで消えるは消えるは消えるということだけ見えてきて
すべてのものは自分というものがね
そこでこの映えなという映えっていうのは
この怖いということなんです
ここは一般的にまとめています
映えというニャーの知恵が生まれる
別にこの瞬間的なもので
ちょっとした気持ちみたいなもの
映えっていうのは あの脅威
怖いような言葉なんですけど
なんか怖いような感覚が生まれるんですね
何年も消えるんだから
もう何もなくなっちゃって
まあこんな調子だったら
まあどうしようもないんだと
この存在っていうのは
まあどうにもならんもんで
もう無意味だって嫌ですよというふうな
自分がこういう調子でずっと生きてるんだったら
もうこれ危ないと ふうなような感じなんですね
すごい強烈な感じなんですけど
その状態になってくると
もう本人がもうヴィパッサナー修行するところじゃなくて
もう道場からもう逃げて生きたいと
お坊さんたちなんか黄色い色さえも嫌ですよ
見て指示を受けるどころか
すっごいこの鋭い感覚が生まれてきます
でもまあ逃げたいんだけど
逃げることも その人はもう集中力できてるんだからあまりしませんだけど
その状態になると まあ教える側がものすごく明確に知ってます
その時はその人のことを随分大事に
その時ですよ 初めて優しい言葉を言うのは
そこまで指導者っていうのはとんでもないことを言ってもけなしちゃうんです
それで本人が泣きながらもう嫌です
もう何もできないんだと泣くんです
すごく で そこで慰めてあげるんですね
それはもうその時のことですから
今は何も言いませんだけどね
で 慰めてちょっともらっちゃうと
まあもうちょっとだけなんですけど
頑張ってみるんだというふうな気持ちになるんです
そこまでね 褒めて愛情あってね
まあ可愛がってくるんだったら
やっぱり申し訳ないんだから
もうちょっとやってみるという気持ちになるんです
それで 映えっていうのは恐怖感であって
この普通の恐怖感とは違います
智慧から生まれる恐怖
怖いという 例えば電気の仕事をしている人が我々よりどれほど怖いかということを知っているでしょう
微生物の研究しているプロが
微生物は体に入ったらどれほど怖いかということをちゃんと知っているんです
ですから その人の恐怖感と我々は微生物は嫌いだ
怖いだという恐怖感というのは
もう全く桁外れに違うものなんです
それで恐怖感 映え生まれてきて
人飛びますけど やっと飽きる
前の質問にあったような飽きる気持ちが生まれてくるんです
それはニッピダニャーナというんです
ニッピダニャ 生きることに
生命を維持し続けることによって飽きちゃうんです
もう何も意味がないんだ
次にもう生きることをやめたいと
これはムンチクカンネタというのです
いわゆるまあ輪廻ですか
この生き続けること これはから何か逃げなくちゃいけないという気持ちが初めて生まれる
それは本物の解脱したいという気持ちなんです
今までの悟りたい 解脱したい
修行したいというのは全部もう偽善です
わかってもないのに 本当は生きることは楽しいんだと思っているくせに
まあなんか修行でもしますと
仏教でも聞いてみます
そんなもん偽善です ですから
いくら真面目にヴィパッサナーしても
この高いレベルの智慧が生まれない限りは偽善なんです
そこでギュッギュッと輪廻のことを存在のことを体験した人が
最後の瞬間でやっぱりもう逃げた方がいいと
脱出した方がいいという気持ちが生まれてきて
その気持ちが生まれて
もう間もないうちに悟りの心が生まれるんです
でもそれにはものすごい今ももう丁寧に修行しなくちゃいけない
そこら辺に行ったらそれからなんですね
質問にあったような いろいろ真言
なんとかなんとかあったんですね
あの五力とかね そういうものを大事に
努力もすることも 修行
瞑想することも 集中力も観察能力も大事に守って
それだけは忘れない いわゆる観察すること
きちんと間が空けないで
堕落しないで観察し続けることはすごく必要なんです
そういう人々は もうその調子になっちゃったら
もう食べなくてもいいんです
もうもし次に仕事に行かなくちゃいけないんだと瞑想して
そこまでもう突然進んだならば
もう仕事をクビになっても構いません
どこがなんか変なことやったら
また心はもとに普通の集中力落ちますからね
ですから もう家が火事になってるんだと思ったっても
逃げない方がいいんです
それで瞑想をちょっとし続けた方がいいです
なぜならば この五力やら七覚支とかなどなどの必要な心の条件
揃ってもらって中道的なものに持ってくるんです
ムンチットガンネタところで
大体自然にはそうなるんです
そこまでずっと長い間修行したんだから
これ一番高いレベルのことを言ってるんです
そこでさっと心 名色が消えたと
名色が寂滅を体験したという
このその味わいっていう
この気持ちが 悟りの心がすぐに瞬間生まれるんですね
この瞬間なんですけど
それで結構煩悩は消えちゃうんです
本人がいろんな言葉で表現できます
自分の心と体と働きっていうのは
ある瞬間きれいさっぱり消えて
完全にもう何もない 無だというためにもそこに意識がないと
という あの まあ仏教用語で言えば
ナーマルーパニローで
ナーマルーパの滅を感じたになったという言うし
またある人がやっと終わったと
まあそこまでやととわかった
あるいはある人は結局は何もなかったと
今まで必死になって生きてきたんだけど
結局元々からもうもう何もなかったと
というふうな もう人なりの言葉ですから
いろいろ表現するかもしれませんだけど
で その経験自体は まあ本当の経験がないかっていうのは
本人が重々知ってるし
まあ一応指導した人も知ってるし
その二人しか知らない
まあそんなことをねですね
一応この このほとんどのヴィパッサナー瞑想というのは準備瞑想みたいなもんなんです
準備して準備して このある強力な心のレベルのところの行くために準備するんです
で 俗的な例えで言うならば
オリンピックに出たくて準備することと同じなんで
小さい時からも準備する
準備一つもオリンピックじゃないんです
いろんなやってやって
もう全く それで最後にいろんな競技に勝って
それから合宿ですかして
もう学校もやめて もうそればっかりやったりして
朝から晩まで厳密にコンピューターまで持ってきて計算しながら
食べ物やら体の動きやら呼吸やら何百回でもコントロールしながら
心の状態までまたもう訓練準備するでしょ
オリンピック出る人は
そこでオリンピック競技に出たら
2  3 秒で終わりと それは本物であって
でも例えば高跳び 跳ぶ
スキーで行って跳ぶことにしたっても
これ 1 分もかからないでしょうに
その 1 分もかからないことに一生かけて準備するんです
ヴィパッサナーも で ヴィパッサナーの本当のところに行ったら
もう時間かからない瞬間の出来事なんですけど
そこまで準備はかかるんです
そういうふうな例えででも覚えておいてください
ですから 七覚支も綺麗に自然に育てていく
マッサティ それからタクホー覚支
それからまあ えーと ショージン覚支とか
まあその順番でちゃんと育てていきます
私たちの仕事はずっと確認することだけですと
とにかく確認することだけは
欠けず もう負けず 怠けずやるぞと
判断はしないと 判断する必要はない
いつでもまだまだですよ
もっと頑張らなくちゃという気持ちはずっと追ってくるんです
まだ不完全だよと まだ納得いってないんだと
そういうこの不満感というのは
ヴィパッサナーでずっと追ってくる
それである日はいくらかのステップには飛びた
飛んだよという気持ちが出てきます
それは第一番目の悟りなんです
いくらかのレベルにはなりましたと
でもまだあるんだと いくらかのレベルになった人は
まあレベルになったんだから
それは落ちることはない
そういうふうなことで
まあすっごい綺麗にできているシステムなんです
ですから 誤解は生まれません
悟ったという誤解も生まれません
正直であるならば 以上です
じゃあ途中で何か現れた質問ございますか？まだ明確ない...